it's time to babble the [ __ ] on live
from the Jon Lovitz arghast theatre icks
Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
[Music]
[Music]
it is it's Saturday night in Hollywood
man so let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm
Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman Wow Wow
I was I'm a little giggly because
literally [ __ ] 40 seconds ago I was
like do we have time they're like
totally I'm like great
and then I heard and then I heard live
for mamas only [ __ ] I was coming down
the hill and as I got to the bottom of
the of the stairs I would anyway boy
it's gonna be a [ __ ] fun show yes and
I'll tell you why not just the [ __ ]
weed thing this is astounding I know I'm
a little late
today I watched the Hunger Games ah
anybody else had this same experience
with it I've you know [ __ ] again but I
hate I'm not gonna turn it into like all
weed humour night but I was stoned and I
kicked back watch this movie did you see
it no I did not you didn't see it no I
ain't even [ __ ] lying dude 10 minutes
in I was bawling like a [ __ ] I was so
emotionally invested in this movie and
is that because people were hungry in it
and then makes you upset I was like I
feel their pain it's no game when you're
hungry
they should eat oh it's it's [ __ ]
beautiful this one chick like steps up
for her sister because your sisters
gonna go get that kill then this [ __ ]
like spoilers like of the you know these
kids they pull few from each district
two from each district make them fight
in this quasi futuristic world where I
don't know what the [ __ ] we did to the
government but the government is so mad
at everyone else that they're like every
year you will feel every district will
give to children who will fight to the
death it'll be one winner out of all
like 24 [ __ ] kids just like American
Idol
yeah fight to the death
yeah man seeing a lot I would watch that
show in that instance if it was just
like you sing it goes to the top of
pyramid of who sings the best isn't
alike and now with the physical
challenge oh it was [ __ ] nuts dude
liked it like the beginning of the movie
like I thought I was like a kids movie
cuz you know it's like kids in it's
based on kids book my kid had to read it
for school last year [ __ ] so I was like
this is gonna be like medicine and then
they [ __ ] send the kids in to fight
for the first time they'd put them up
these [ __ ] tubes and they all come
out in this field and shift they're
counting down from [ __ ] 30 I think or
maybe 60 was irritatingly long remember
I was stoned yeah I wanted to I wanted
to get the games going and [ __ ] and this
is like the half hour mark and finally
it's like been and they [ __ ] race for
all this equipment that's laid out the
mouth of the cornucopia they call it and
I'm not even [ __ ] [ __ ] you dude
I'm like it's a pg-13 movie but it was
one of the most savage [ __ ] things
I've ever seen
these kids are like going for these
[ __ ] backpacks and [ __ ] and other
kids are coming with machetes like ah
it's [ __ ] Savage they're killing
other kids right there on the field
there and you hear cannons going off
every time a kid dies I'm sitting there
next to my wife I'm like I'm so in and
it was like over two hours long like
every movie these days now is way over -
yeah I don't care for that I this I
didn't mind this I was literally like
keep going keep going
no more kids kill more kids oh it was
astounding I can't believe that this
passes today for entertained and that
kids wanted to go see there's like we
want to see each other killing each
other because that's what they do it's
just teenagers going like I'm the top of
the food chain
now I'm it's kind of like a mini like a
Highlander high school or something like
that there can be only one and you know
I don't know I recommend seeing it it's
[ __ ] it's pretty tight I was so
[ __ ] into I was literally yelling at
the screen and [ __ ] rotten Katniss
she's good with bow and arrow yeah that
Jennifer Hudson know what's good
Jennifer what Lawrence Jennifer Lawrence
Murrell worids yeah yeah you got that
you're the [ __ ] excuse me tonight cuz
I got a I got a just a Chelsea Handler
of a head cold
it's a bad one
so I am all kind of looped up on [ __ ]
medicine I've got dayquil and nyquil and
noon quill and now is the perfect time
to watch Hunger Games I'm all I'm when
you're done tonight you go home pop that
[ __ ] in it'll change your life you'll
[ __ ] wake up the next morning be
nicer to people now alright that's not
gonna happen take a lot more than one
movie for that to happen to me I don't
know it's a special film I looked at
that future and I was just like oh [ __ ]
I don't want the world to be like that
so I start being nicer to everybody
right away made my wife some eggs and
[ __ ] like that I'm just stocking up on
bows and arrows that's all I'm doing cuz
I will [ __ ] take somebody out there
was one chick who like whips [ __ ]
knives like these again spoilers if you
haven't seen it or read it like came out
like eight years ago I don't think I was
gonna see it they've seen it say you
apparently I was the last one man I was
the holdout they at one point she
[ __ ] cuts a branch down has a Oh like
a wasp nest a hornet's nest but they're
you know like genetically altered
versions of it tracker jackers a man
said that Cracker Jack Earth
I think I write a tracker jackers in the
back of my local video store that in the
curtain section back there we're the
tracker jackers throughout the woods and
just spank it on a tree is that what the
plot is yeah tracked each other by the
goose Danes the tracker jackers it's so
weird like in terms of you here tracker
jacker and what you go with is they hunt
each other with calm yes the tracker
jackers Ralph she knocks the whole
[ __ ] part of him down
they attack [ __ ] all these kids one
this chick gets stung the [ __ ] out if
she's like well it looks like keV Smith
on Southwest Airlines and then [ __ ]
the other chick takes the bow and ours
it's a pretty [ __ ] brutal flick for a
pg-13 they do that dark night thing
where you know like in dark night Keith
Ledger used knives a lot but they always
cut away and there was always more of an
implication of violence than like look
at the blood same thing here man but
they have shots it's so [ __ ] up where
you just see him like that's like Lord
of the Flies or just [ __ ] each other
up man I was just like I wish High
School been like this because I'd win
the Hunger Games as one game I could
competed well great there was a positive
review for a movie came out three years
ago hey come here to Hollywood babble-on
to get all the latest breaking news in
show business Jennifer Lawrence is good
we've established that yes I like during
winter bone - she's good in that ever
see winter boned yes I did at first
thought you said wit her bone I was like
she has a bone yeah Winter's Bone yes
where she played a young Rebecca romaine
and mystique speak canada's geek test
yes
okay okay so we've got that out of the
way
yeah yeah yeah I can I do I apologize
for my boys this evening it might be a
little croaky as we go on because I am
suffering a little bit but I am
well-oiled I've got dr. Jack here taking
care of me tonight might be Jack
Kevorkian but it says dr. Jack I've got
to be honest I don't even hear it in
your voice that's good because I feel
like [ __ ]
really but the way you're talking it's
just like you'd think your voice was
just like well perhaps she's wondering
why you would shoot too bad but you
sound like Ralph you don't sound [ __ ]
up who's then let's get to the the
shoutouts portion of the show
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe I wouldn't win the Hunger Games
surely wouldn't you'd starve of all they
were served it was [ __ ] the shoutouts of
course is that part of the show where we
say like an awesome [ __ ] movie man
that now I think about that's what's
missing from that though I can [ __ ]
in order to win put a dick in your mouth
we'll see who's really hungry that was
tracker jackers that was the movie I was
talking about shoutouts is the segment
of the show where we say hello to people
or come particularly long distances or
celebrating special occasions we give
them a shout-out and tonight I want to
see if Tiffany and Elliot are here
Tiffany and Elliot are you here yes and
once again and I mention this every week
and it's a podcast which is primarily an
hour all experience where people need to
hear something so let's try this again
don't [ __ ] yell at people just
because you're sick do now it's funny
didn't make you sick well I'm gonna make
them sick in about a minute Tiffany and
Elliot do you guys hear there we go
that's the course fun they're having
you're like the [ __ ] dude in
Schindler's you like tells him about
[ __ ] chicken
Tiffany writes will be at the show
celebrating my husband's birthday his
name is Elliot he's a big fan and uses
the number 37 for all his softball and
basketball team numbers there you go
it'd be nice if you could send him a
shout-out this is our first time
checking out the show and I guess after
my berating you it'll be the last time
as well I think they left two minutes
ago so sorry can we catch them in the
parking lot and see if they want to come
back and I'll buy them a drink by the
way if you want to give a shout-out for
those listening at home if you're gonna
be in the show it's HBO podcast at
aol.com is the email address people
often ask us how do I get in touch with
you and I say we set it a [ __ ] lot so
if you don't know
and I don't want you to write it but HBO
podcast a day well done and also if you
want to relive this exact [ __ ] moment
or a few others from the show man on
Monday morning you go to youtube.com
slash loud and you can watch clips from
this episode on the loud Channel it's
like a mini TV show of Hollywood a
little 10-minute taste if you will just
not just a little bit of a tip and neck
no [ __ ] balls whatsoever no shaft be
holy now no chef whatsoever it's just
late stick pre-cum really yeah the
pre-cum really oh I thought you said it
was pretty calm I was like is that a
thing man
again stubby hands I'm having a hard
time back like here it comes I love you
wife here's my pretty come it's my least
favorite gesture you did it ever now
think about if you put pretty at the fun
to come like it would go over a lot
smoother man we said come people I kill
it's all biscuits and [ __ ] but when you
go pretty calm they're like oh it's like
a pony pretty sounds like a song from
Mary Poppins pretty common pretty come
pretty come pretty come pretty dumb
pretty come oh you put you copy and then
penguins come out dancing dripping
[Laughter]
how about Kyle and Amy are you guys here
tonight you brought people with you Kyle
and Amy I think you terrified them with
the earlier couple and [ __ ] like
screamed we don't you don't know me but
help me out when he says my name can you
make some noise I'm afraid of what he'll
do
Kyle writes my girlfriend Amy is from
Philadelphia well god bless you Amy so
am i and is leaving California to move
back there after two years you coward
she is a Batman fan then it is a sad
time so I wish she could have Christian
Bale wish her luck or convince her to
stay that would be great so Kyle this is
your girlfriend girlfriend and she's
leaving you and you're still taking her
out on a date you're spending money on
her I'm just saying there is a there is
a questionable return on your investment
there if you're spending money on the
girl and taking her out and she's
leaving I'm still stuck on girlfriend
girlfriend well that when when there's
[ __ ] it's way more official to you if
their girlfriend girlfriends well you
say my girlfriend's like your female
friend girlfriend girlfriend which means
you put it in and only with the
girlfriend girlfriend can you pretty
come treating everybody I'm pretty
comforting I'm pretty good pretty good
pretty good pretty boy pretty come
so you're from Philadelphia Amy and
you're a Batman fan give me five minutes
to break up my wife and you can stay in
California because that's all I need
right there Batman that's why you live
in California if I may be so bold to ask
for school what's in Philadelphia school
wise for you
Drexel University Axl they got a dragon
on the side man that's a cool school
it's like going to [ __ ] Hogwarts
it is the Drexel school of wizardry
absolutely yeah one of the big five so
Christian Bale wishing her luck or
convincing her to stay this time
is it a Calliphora because you I need
someone to fight crime you're a
California cuz I'm going to retire
because I'm going to take like eight
years off and then I'm and then I'm just
gonna [ __ ] and quit completely so I want
to hand over the job to someone much
less qualified than me I'll just give
you the keys to the waterfall and I'm
gonna get some coffee with Catwoman have
a good trip back to Philadelphia
sweetheart give Philly my love I miss it
it's actually not a bad rendition at the
end of that movie spoilers the more I
think about the more just get mad yeah I
got a thorn in my paw about that one
particularly the ending the beginning
[Music]
listen to you really yeah I don't want
to spoilers because anyone hasn't seen
it here but a couple years from now
we'll talk about Dark Knight Rises like
we talked about Hunger Games and you'll
hear my aunt you know I really feel
Robert from Seattle are you here
hello Robert from Seattle Ralph I need
you to let Kevin Smith know how upset I
am Kevin was in Seattle back in March
and he tweeted afterwards he wanted to
get some dicks afterwards we were
excited when we heard this I mean how
often can you treat a star like Kevin
Smith to some dicks so we waited and
waited for him we were sadly
disappointed because he was a no-show I
mean here are some guys eager to treat
him some hot dicks after a long show I
know he would have loved the dicks that
we were going to give him something want
to talk about hey I did in fact there's
a fast-food or out there oh it's called
dick well that explains everything
totally and I after show I said I'm
gonna go get some dicks and you say that
for every show yeah only that time
people were laughing I was like it's not
funny so I did have dicks I just didn't
go myself but somebody else went for me
oh you Hollywood superstar the [ __ ]
stage I was just like man I'd love some
dicks like let's go I was like I'd love
it if somebody else would go for me
well Robert says now several months
later Here I am in Los Angeles to see
Hollywood babble-on and it's time to
make up for Kevin missing some dicks so
this time I have to go solo and treat
him to some of the old in-and-out
[Applause]
somebody's getting lucky after the show
well welcome Robert thanks for coming
all the way from welcome and thank you
for figuring out how to cram some dick
jokes into this show into this show
because we don't have enough always been
our weakness not enough dick jokes in
the show how about eric boe work is eric
Bojorquez correctly yes it sound like a
[ __ ] Bond villain 707 what do you
know about Eric Bojorquez well he's a
world-known assassin there's three
nipples if I'm not mistaken that's like
on Twitter people keep saying like Bane
sounds like Sean Connery it kind of does
when you try bane he sounds like a jerk
he sounds like a German Sean Connery
almost go I'm afraid you have to imagine
what the fire feels like that sound good
yeah oh let me try crashing this plane
[Music]
eirick right you guys are the perfect
dynamic duo drunk man and puffed cloud
it would be a good comic book bringing
my brother and my wife Lucy to see you
guys for the first time live do the fact
that I talk about you guys constantly
they are both thoroughly convinced I
want you both inside me why can't people
just be fans I don't know I do get some
dicks with Robert and tell me afterwards
please in your alchemy chino voice could
you convince my wife but i'm not gay
just because i talk about you guys all
the time it does not mean i want both of
your penises in my mouth at the same
time at the same time right taking turns
let's be civilized
that's code Wow eirick Bojorquez eric
Bojorquez eric Bojorquez
i'm just gonna keep saying that cuz
that's fun to say Wow Eric Bojorquez has
a great ass
all right how about rabble rabble rabble
or what's that Rebell you'll never be
above the only one you didn't choose
Robel are you from the planet Krypton so
my only son my name is rebel and I've
been a huge Kevin Smith fan since my
mother showed me the clerk's cartoon
when I was about six or seven child
services hello lady
although she never let me watch his
other work till I was older I instantly
fell in love with the comic genius that
is Kevin Smith so much so that I was
willing to wait in line for about eight
hours at the age of seven to meet Kevin
at the opening of his secret stash comic
book shop here in Southern California I
have enclosed a picture of me and a
younger Kevin Smith I think we've got
that photo here someplace
look at Kevin and rebell if Kevin
doesn't remember me I'll be heartbroken
because I spent the whole time drawing
Star Wars and Batman pictures for him
and his daughter Harley when I was in
line he has always been the atom West to
my young Ralph Garman well how about
that I want to thank you both for making
a show like this possible to help so
many people myself included make it
through dark times in our lives
well rebel thanks for coming and thanks
to your ankling to be angling the way I
guess it would be ankling is leaving yes
angling is trying angling to be my
[ __ ] young Ward dude I could have my
own Robin
look at them that's that doesn't look
super elegant looks looks like [ __ ] I'm
about to meet that dude who's just like
so Chris Hansen yeah that's what I was
thinking
let me read you from some of your emails
are you boy touch her 37 so I heard you
liked my cartoons I'd like to do some
painting on you with pretty comb pretty
come pretty good pretty good boy pretty
calm is Bram here tonight Bram yeah
Bram Amelia Jim and Steve where's Jim by
the way raise your hand Jim Jim gee why
am i Jim is that right man that's your
spelling of it right that's not how
you're actually spelling your spell yeah
so you walk around this Jay I am yeah
base to him based on that reaction you
better the man why would people get so
uptight about that like you [ __ ] jerk
cuz it's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up if
somebody's like Jim and I'm gonna put
that in the script what's your day and
Jim
oh like James know like gymnasium yeah
my parents were health nuts copyright
keV Smith and Brahm we're all here all
the way from Toronto Canada
well welcome you know we're gonna be
Canada next week you could have stuck
around when is safety the airfare
we're going to Ottawa's that next week
going out away in next we got an Ottawa
Babylon that's forgery come see us here
man also diplomatic immunity no
I'm hoping you can help Steve who's in
dire need of some laughs UCLA seems to
hate him
i funny I thought they hated Jim but I
know apparently they hate Steve in four
days Steve has been spit on and accosted
by a crazy hobo in Venice we don't call
him hobos anymore first of all they're
just bums
he was egged on melrose [ __ ] Steve is
that what they're calling in my days we
called it blown no he actually had an
egg thrown at him Oh something all the
kids are saying I got [ __ ] egged last
night man [ __ ] dozen we think it has
something to do with the fact that
Steve's earlobes are ridiculously large
and gooey
leaves earlobes now they're almost jello
like inconsistency therefore only the
jello master himself Bill Cosby can
comfort Steve can bill please tell Steve
that everything will be okay and that la
is not at all Zoey's and no go on
Melrose because they will throw daggered
you so you're right it is a hellhole I'm
sorry
Bill Cosby just confirmed it
[Applause]
mark and Shannon are you guys hello
welcome I love you guys so much can't
believe my awesome sexy husband Mark
bought tickets for us to see your show
for my 40th birthday I was so excited to
be in your presence and I was hoping
you'd do me the honor of celebrating
with a little David Bowie well of course
I love both of you guys so much and if
it wasn't married to an amazing man I
would jump you both love Shannon
maybe we're married to amazing women
yeah maybe Mark our husbands a big [ __ ]
block that's what I think
wasn't for mark we'd be getting a little
tail totally right keep doing the wobbly
age with Shannon
welcome to Babel in PS please tell mark
he's getting a kick-ass [ __ ] for this
Wow your ass kicked
mark kicks you right in the ass where's
[ __ ] ever okay sorry about the cold
again the little Bowie a happy birthday
for a Shannon's fortieth all right here
we go
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you you don't look 40 years old
you look like 39 maybe 39
[Music]
happy sweaty bit man yeah it is such a
workout I should really just do that at
home they'll be amazing if you called me
every hour on the hour right and I
picked up the phone get ready James I
pick up the phone all I hear is this
hello time for you to work out kids
thanks Ralph
time for you to I'm gonna wind it again
so maybe not every hour about maybe not
six hours or something like that once a
week I'm sorry I was thinking this up
before I was happy to do the dance but
as you started to sing before I was like
let's do a different version of David
Bowie Happy Birthday song
Bowie music right Bill Cosby singing
James I'm sick then are you can make me
jump through hoops really my own
performing Android or something like
that we also get emails from all around
the world and we'd like to address them
as well featuring Kevin's reactions
remember Steve the poolman from last
week's singing Kuhlman sang to his lady
she like literally wept did and she did
more than that apparently according to
this email ralph Kevin thank you so much
for the greatest nights of my life I did
not get a call back from the voice of
Titian on Sunday but I did get sax on
Saturday night thanks to you guys and no
Kevin I didn't get the balloon not
that's from Steve the pool man so why
does he assumed I would ask about the
balloon nah you're the ass guy but it's
so weird that the dude just like I had
the greatest night of my life
that's next yeah this next email comes
from Isabel my husband I love listening
to your show it's our two-year wedding
anniversary coming this Tuesday but it's
our first time actually celebrating it
together last year he was deployed when
our one-year anniversary rolled around
so this year it's very special for us it
would mean a lot and surprise my husband
Dave is a big fan of Pharrell could give
us advice for a long and happy marriage
as TVs Batman Adam West thanks for all
the laughs Isabel well Isabel
I believe you've already mastered the
secret to a perfect marriage spend half
of your time apart always worked for me
and Burt Yeah right like they weren't
okay this email comes from Jason from
the Twin Cities and this is why I like
having the email portion because long
time answers are provided for questions
that I didn't know people were asking
here we go
fair enough thanks for all the free
funny Ralph whenever you mentioned
everyone's favorite Parent Trap star
turned to coke [ __ ] you always scream
with an affected voice that sounds a
little like a weird Adam Sandler you
explain everything on the show you've
explained the creepy clown bit 25 times
but I've never heard explanation about
why you used that voice for her what's
that all about Jason from the Twin
Cities and I realized I've never brought
that up before okay it stems from an old
video which features a drunken P Diddy
Puff Daddy do I did he he is drunk off
his ass and he's talking about the fact
that he was a spokesperson for Proactiv
acne solution right and after he did it
Lindsay Lohan and Jessica Simpson also
did commercials for proactive and it
makes him very upset and he's drunk off
his ass talking into the to the video
camera bitching about how they sort of
followed his lead and he's very drunk
and when he says the words
that's how he says it and I always
thought it was very funny that he
pronounced it in a drunken slurring way
like that and I just sort of adopted
that years ago and I never really
explained anybody why I go Nick but I
brought in the video so you can see for
yourself the origin of Lindsay Lohan
here's it here the drunk P Diddy as he
was known men talking about Proactive
y'all know damn well you know damn well
that
Lindsay Lohan and definitely Simpson
we're not using no proactive oh did you
woah proactive now don't Linda skincare
products now now y'all think it's
official well I got a few hours off on
Proactiv for seven years
as long I've seen smooth cocoa butter
school there you go there's Lohan now
now Lindsay Lohan so that's where that
comes from
mark Gillard of Palm Coast Florida
writes last weekend I was driving to
dinner with my sister and boyfriend I
put on some Hollywood babble-on for the
car ride neither my sister nor her
boyfriend had ever heard the phrase
rusty wagon wheel before fast-forward a
half an hour we're sitting at our table
at a restaurant ordering drinks my
sister's boyfriend smartass that he is
told the waiter he wanted a rusty wagon
wheel they got a laugh from the waiter
but also led to a lengthy discussion in
our table about what a rusty wagon wheel
would consist of I think you should ask
other HBO fans to come in with their own
recipes and send them in the winning
recipe would become the real rusty wagon
wheel served at the Jon Lovitz podcast
theater thanks for everything babble the
[ __ ] on I think that's a great idea
I'm not a drinker but I support it so
send in your recipes for what you think
a rusty wagon wheel would be to HBO
podcast at aol.com well we'll get the
best of them will make them and then
we'll have like a taste test one week
I'll bring them all up here and we'll
taste five and the myrrh someone will
pick a winner yoohoo and vodka
do I win I think that's what we call the
slippery pedophile once again let me
read some of your emails are you you who
37 I'd like to give you a drink
it's delicious chocolatey and will get
you very relaxed I was still laughing
inside from earlier when you called me
boy touch her 37 that would be your
creepy pedophile email it to me don't
you think like I try to hide it be like
[ __ ] Star Wars fan 37 or something
when you put boy touch you right away
the government's like you should keep an
eye on this guy that's why you got
caught by Christmas
I'm not good at you're not good at all
last week we introduced a new TV show
Kevin's very excited about the magic
kicking in man starring John Travolta
as the gay ghost this fall on NBC John
Travolta is the gay ghost s macron any
one of our listeners sent in the first
ad apparently that NBC is running for
this here's the the new print ad for the
new show coming up and that leads us
into this week's creepy clown time we
have a little creepy clown time music
[Music]
alright this week's a creepy clown sign
comes from tots key listener tots key
last week the appearance of the gay
ghost had me pissing my pants with
laughter the only way to top it gay
ghost creepy clown time babble the [ __ ]
on Tatsuki alright this is John Travolta
as the gay ghost doing the creepy clown
putting on his makeup for Kevin Smith
dude it's so weird
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do boo I thought you forgot
the boo I would never forget the boom oh
I'm gonna listen to this show because
I'm not gonna remember any of it tonight
every week we say goodbye to some people
in show business who deserve a special
send up as they slough off this mortal
coil it's known [ __ ] comedy show dude
it's known as the Tinseltown steps and
now another edition of
[Music]
they will be missed you have won yeah
yeah we should talk before the show some
probably yeah good Helen Gurley Brown
the famed cosmopolitan editor
cosmopolitan magazine of course you
ladies I'm sure you all subscribe
because how else would you learn 27
mind-blowing SEC tricks to keep him
around SEC trick sex tricks you know
what I meant I like to have sex and
pretty common pretty coming pretty good
pretty good single girl was the name of
her 1962 book that was her big claim to
fame that brought her a lot of notoriety
and then she started putting together
Cosmo magazine which bit basically
became a Playboy magazine for women from
1965 to 1997 she was the editor of that
magazine then she sold it for a lot of
money she died at 90 years old this week
although the New York Times said in
their obituary she was 90 although parts
of her were considerably younger which i
think is a shitty thing to write in the
New York Times about so it's weird she
was married to David Brown without whom
we wouldn't have jobs that's right many
other movies but you all introduced her
which they just came out with a blu-ray
have you seen it you can't get it
anywhere it's like selling out left and
right is it really yeah I guess in like
Best Buy they had like a special case
four inch I just got one off Amazon like
a regular standard blu-ray edition but
it's [ __ ] the transfers beautiful
looks like they shot the film like not
too long ago and there's a extra on the
you know there's been many documentaries
about the making of Jaws but they have
one on the blu-ray I think it's on the
second disc maybe it's the first disc
but it's called the shark is still
working its documentary like I talked
about a few years ago I think and I had
a copy for a long time it is so good it
was made by fans about jaws so it covers
every aspect like the [ __ ] the guy
who did the voice over perceive odd
Regas it was like there was a beast of
the sea you know that guy the dude who
painted the poster if I get everybody
got Roy Scheider before he died Peter
Benchley before he died if you were
remotely interested in Jaws this talk
is mine minimally good not only is it a
really great documentary about a movie
is one of like the 20 best documentaries
I've ever seen so much love and
attention to details put into it so if
you see a copy of the Jaws blu-ray
definitely watch jaws of course but Papa
pop in the other disk or if it's on the
same disc I can't remember and check out
the shark is still working it is so
mind-bendingly good man it covers
everything true fans made it also passed
away this week Ron Palillo who played
horse shack on Welcome Back Kotter that
wasn't mine but that was his thing he
would go Oh mr. Kotter Oh big laugh
suffered a heart attack at the age of 63
this week [ __ ] bummer man yeah he he
had a heart to heart go of it after
horse shake that character was such I
know it sounds crazy but it was such a
big hit back in the day when there was
only three networks and that show blew
up of course John Travolta got his start
on that show but his character was on
lunchboxes and t-shirts he's like the
Fonz you know in terms of the success of
that character he could not get away
from the typecasting him that character
and he was like one of the first if you
look at the history of like TV
characters he was like the first kind of
distill it and whether he consciously
did it or not too like a catchphrase and
a [ __ ] war of wardrobe piece article
of clothing yeah like they say people
like Arkell later on were made in the
same exact mould it was the first geek
TV star really much after 79 when the
show went off the air he had some bit
parts here and there on the a-team and
Love Boat and that kind of stuff but
later went into teaching acting and he
was teaching in Florida when he had the
heart attack he was rushed to the
hospital by the weight up his he was a
gay gentleman and his partner Joseph
Graham rushed him to the hospital they
were together for 41 years
that's it [ __ ] yeah man and in that's
41 years gay couple that's eight years
three years
I'd be like 102 or something
it's very impressed I'm so glad there's
some people out there who want to keep
the gays from being married because you
can't have that sort of devotion for 41
years to one person it just makes the
rest of us look bad so please by all
means don't let the gays get married
huge bucket of windows guy here's a
little taste if you've never seen
Welcome Back Kotter here's a little
taste from the the first episode of
Welcome Back Kotter where we first meet
Arnold horshack Arnold the West why the
last project because after they made me
they broke the mold
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so weird huge pocket when he I read an
article this week where they talked
about like the laughs was all him he
just said he says what he said just now
and then it just said he laughs and that
was the laugh he brought to it and that
was the laughs that became his like
defining trademark absolutely if you
missed and also Helen Gurley Brown huge
bucket of [ __ ] went on before a
massive cab I'm so bored
yes design I'm sorry I had to add to
that that was actually the laugh I read
an article as well about it and the
laugh was a kind of a tribute to his
father who I think was had passed from
lung cancer or something that effect so
he kind of modeled that laugh after his
father's kind of wheezing as a kind of a
tribute to him right on man TJ James
with some [ __ ] information or you
know doing done maybe I was have any
facts about horseshit I'd like to share
before we get on with the rest of the
show he was a huge fan of the pretty cub
if you're a comic book fan that you were
sad to hear that artist Joe Kubert
passed away this week he was a legend
legend in history probably babe earth to
legends as well well not personally but
helped in the process it's like comic
book artist school really they credited
one in the United States in 1976 start
his own Academy best known for his work
with Tarzan I guess was a big character
that he driving of Hawkman Hoffman let's
throw up some Hawkman by the way Little
Joe's Hawkman yeah that's great stuff
and Sergeant Rock of course was his
character that fighting gentleman goes
yeah they sure that just makes me want
to read a comic right there and this
gentleman goes one of the worst [ __ ]
villains because look at him maybe the
big white tuxedo yeah and he's a [ __ ]
ghost like I could go with a lot of [ __ ]
if you're like hey man these guys have
wings in a big maces I'll go I'm like
that could be happening right but when
you show me the ghost with no head and
[ __ ] I'm like I'm out this is [ __ ]
man
like his [ __ ] Superman remember when
I was a kid I saw Superman and at the
end of the Superman movie he's mad
spoilers he's my [ __ ] 1970 or
spoilers
he's mad cos lo he's Lois got killed in
the mist and [ __ ] so he goes backwards
around the earth to change its rotation
and then that turns back time yeah and I
remember that movie came out and we see
77 was Star Wars 78 was Superman so I'm
8 years old even at 8 years old I was
just like Superman can't do this this is
horseshit because Superman can't do this
and my father was just like Superman
can't do anything school Jew he did bad
he put it on Front Street he was just
like don't be a dick Kevin let the
internet do that in 30 years and I was
like right on dad you know a lot of
people misunderstand that final scene
and they think that Superman is turning
the earth backwards on its axis but in
reality what Superman is doing is
meeting reaching maximum velocity he's
traveling faster than light yeah and an
Einstein said if you can break that
speed you could actually travel through
time so we're watching the world spin
backwards only because Superman is
traveling backwards in time he's not
really turning the planet separately
[Applause]
I don't know what movie you saw Ralph
but when I saw the earth went backwards
and my [ __ ] like doing this [ __ ] that
was the intention yeah I don't think it
was represent listen to me [ __ ] like
talk about another director but I that
hack richard donner i just visually i
don't think that was representing me it
was not really who turned the [ __ ]
earth backwards Jennifer as many years
as I saw it ago what is that [ __ ]
1978 what now is it 20 34 years 40 years
34 years almost yeah yeah for 34 years
man it's never been what you said so
it'll never be that to me I can't change
what 34 [ __ ] years though no new
information for you is no change we fear
it and while we're talking about
Superman his mom passed away this week
Phyllis Thaxter who played ma Kent in
the 1978 movie Superman died at the age
of 92 this week she had been an actor
since the 30s she was on Broadway in the
30s work friends yam in the 40s did
television in the 50s and 60s had to
stop in the 50s for a while because she
had polio got better started working
again and then Donner cast her as ma
Kent in Superman I brought a little
taste of that film the one we were just
talking about Superman probably my
favorite moment of the early opening of
that film when they discovered the baby
kal-el in that rocket ship well this
ain't the baby Dixie no it's not the
baby dick scene
cuz that'd be creepy of y'all my
favorite scene and Superman is I'm
Batman fan 66 I'd like to say more baby
dick if you don't mind I'm Chris Hansen
you're free to go here is Mach n trying
to talk pocket in the fact that they
should adopt this new alien baby they
just found by the side of the road
here's a little scene from Superman
the first thing we got to do when we get
home is find out who that boys proper
family he hasn't got any not around here
anyway
mother are you thinking what I think
you're thinking we could say he's the
child of my cousin in North Dakota and
just now often
Oh Jonathan he's only a baby Martha now
you saw how we found Martha Clark Kent
are you listening to what I'm saying
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I still get chills when that makes you
know I almost cried yeah that makes me
want to watch them but that movie holds
up he is so [ __ ] good Christopher
Reeve as Clark Kent and Superman yeah
just like when you think of the
modern-day superhero like you know you
think about rose oh he must have friends
every week we also like to talk about
some celebrities who are able to get out
of their own heads who are able to get
out of their own egos and to help
someone else it's a segment we call
Hollywood helpers don't do that to the
lick your nipples
this week's Hollywood helper it sounds
like you've got one of your own room I
do and I just read an article that I
thought was really nice but you go first
my Hollywood help her this week is
Dexter star James remar he plays Harry
Dexter's dad on that show who visits him
as a ghost from beyond he was in 48
hours
yeah he was dance ganz yeah we had
brothers waiting partners many friends
began kids away with my money gonna be
sorry you ever met me I'm already sorry
that's my review of 48 hours in 22nd
listen here convict nice yeah Billy
baron
really bad that was the Indian that was
with James remar used to be an EMT
before he became an actor he was outside
a supermarket this week here in Los
Angeles and so on homeless man sitting
out front who had a massive bloody head
wound now most of us give in that
situation would just judge him yes would
say ooh bloody homeless dude yeah James
remar went inside the supermarket bought
bandages and antiseptic came back out
and cleaned and dressed the man's wound
that's cool and didn't do it for press
didn't do anything just walked away TMZ
happened to catch it because I guess
they were following around with cameras
and they they saw him do it but he said
after the fact it was just the right
thing to do when he taught the guy how
to keep it clean and keep it from being
infected and and get a cup of Geico a
couple bucks and went on his way that's
a pretty cool thing very cool then
Michael C Hall came and murdered the
homeless man so sadly was all for naught
but still a nice gesture on James remar
spine he was cleaning that dude up and
suddenly his Dark Passenger was like
gilliam yeah let me throw one out there
I don't have the article but I just read
it the Jay Leno took a massive pay cut
to keep the Tonight Show staff in place
they lost about 20 people or 25 people
in a network cut back Comcast owns NBC
and I guess they cut a bunch of staff
from The Tonight Show in order to keep
as many as they could Leno apparently
took like a deep deep salary cut which I
thought was kind of sweet to keep the
his staff employed and [ __ ] so I say he
is Olle would help bury somebody people
always [ __ ] on and whatnot like he's
[ __ ] not funny he's your grandma's
comic and [ __ ] like that and after the
Conan she had a few years ago
people always shouldn't a dude's mouth
but he's I've dealt with him for years
and he's always been a nice guy classy
guy cares about people whatnot and I
thought that was a really nice move
because he could have just been like
well they're cutting jobs people sorry
and
his money but he's always been the first
to say he's like he makes that Tonight
Show check he puts it in a bank and he
lives off of his live appearance money
which is he almost equal to what he
makes on the show I guess so I thought
it was a cool thing he deserves props
for that you know
this autonomy anything you do to help
someone else keep their job is a good
thing a lot of people losing jobs in
general in this economy and in this
business too you know there's it's
harder and harder to find a movie that
actually shoots in Los Angeles
production keeps going else worse yeah
it's nice that he kept some jobs here
anyway he is a Hollywood it's things a
little bit that tonight's just gonna
stay on the air though because they have
that's a little bit of a sting I don't
know it seems to be even and though it's
not Johnny Carson and Johnny Carson's
been gone for a while
it seems to be kind of a standard though
the way that the shows are rated in
late-night is in increments of about 15
minutes I think even five minutes at San
Lawrence and they had they broke that
show down to me once cuz you know it's
the biggest one in late-night and so you
know you figure like when they say hey
man 6 million people watch it or
something you're like wow 6 million
people are gonna watch me when I'm on
The Tonight Show and that's not the case
at all when the show begins at 11:30
that's when they have their biggest
number everybody's tuned in to watch the
monologue do you know why because a lot
of people aren't newsreaders during the
day and so they figure if they watch the
monologue of a general overview of the
news presented in a light entertaining
way there no that's it out in 10 minutes
and they can be going asleep and that's
generally what happens they watch that
show up to the monologue as soon as the
monologue ends the audience drops off by
almost half well and that's the desk
piece and that's normally like
jaywalking or something like that then
after the desk piece before the first
guest comes the audience drops again by
almost half so by the time the first
guest hits there they got what at that
point half and then half so what
three-quarters of the show or two
quarters the audience is missing you're
not good at math by the time they get to
the second guest which is where I
usually [ __ ] sit there's no one one
my mother's watching and that's it so
people tune out and
this is interesting the the music is the
lowest rated portion of that show so
much so that they don't even count like
the last five to ten minutes of the show
in the ratings they just kind of go like
the show ends at 12:45 or whatever time
it is they don't count it's the isn't
that weird like you would imagine the
music people tuned in for but that's
that's not at all by that point most
people are just sleeping so anyway
there's an overview of The Tonight Show
and still to this day that monologue as
it was in Carson's day is as it is today
is still the monologue that most people
tune in when I say most people did I
mean middle America I mean sure you're
not [ __ ] the coast here in this town
people like nobody watches that show but
somebody watches that show because
there's a big number yeah so anyway a
lot of people here yeah that's all I
hear when I see them I salute what I
watch them all about here ie
he's a leprechaun leprechaun with a
giant chin every week we take a look at
some a-list actors who've given less
than a list performances with the
exquisite acting segment this week it's
a return engagement of jean-luc Picard
from Star Trek The Next Generation
Patrick Stewart stars in this episode of
chain of command is the name of the
episode of Star Trek The Next Generation
this comes from Sven in Germany
I think it's funny savannas from Germany
he should be in Sweden yeah
the card in this episode is being
captured and tortured by the Kardashians
not the kardashians the kardashians
right yeah it was before we knew card
ass SS yeah he's being tortured and
forced to they're trying to control his
mind and so they have a number of lights
in this this room that he's being
tortured in for lights and they keep
trying to get him to say that there's a
different number of lights they know
once they can crack him and make him say
whatever they want him to say they will
have twisted his mind and and his free
will will be gone but jean-luc Picard
will have none of it and they keep
asking him how many lights there are and
he does it in a very Shakespearean way
in this scene just over acting out the
[ __ ]
really for your enjoyment here's Patrick
Stewart telling you how many lights are
in this room with the kardashians from
Star Trek
do we not have picture for a reason we
can we show that again it's funny or if
you look at it what did you say to all
the girls
I'll just move on but let me know all
the videos are gonna be like that for
the rest of the night or else I won't I
won't go
hey hey hey sure it when you got court
horshack facts I can't shut you up but
now you're not giving me nothing
James don't [ __ ] with me six tonight man
you know how he is when he's looking up
like a like a douchebag and no one's
saying anything to me
going to let's go to the next video this
is a signal we call a Sigmund Sigmund
the sea monster and Johnny and Scott our
friends this is a segment all of a
sudden I'm Dean Martin now oh hold on a
second I got a sigmund for everybody
I've got a segment called [ __ ] that
should not be Kevin
[Music]
this is stuff that happens in mainstream
Hollywood movies and TV shows that just
should not have been left in with the
hundreds of people who get eyes on these
things before they reach an audience you
think somebody would say well but that
right there is [ __ ] that just should not
be but they don't and it gets out and
keeping with a sci-fi theme like we did
Star Trek in the previous clip this is
from Logan's Run a classic film from
1976 it's like the original [ __ ]
Hunger Games that's right yeah it's an
idyllic world they live in if you've
never seen the film
yeah there's no war there's no
pestilence there's no there's no hunger
there's no hunger games it's a perfect
sad world bro the perfect world except
no one lives beyond 30 bumbum mmm at 30
they sent you to carousel and carousel
is the promise of everlasting life if
you can rise beyond the top of carousel
you can live past 30 but as we see no
one does you know why because they're
killing everybody the government's
killing everybody at 30 because they
can't afford to feed him anymore yeah so
here's the seat from Logan's Run Michael
York plays Logan he's running in this
film and he takes on the guys what they
call a Sandman these are the people who
catch the runners and he's got a gun
he's shooting people and he's trying to
escape with Jenny Agutter who's just so
[ __ ] hot in this movie and they're
shooting people left to right and in the
background you'll see an extra and now
apparently something went horribly wrong
this extra was supposed to be on fire I
guess and go screaming through the
background of the the shot but the only
his ass is on fire and it looks really
silly for a guy in an orange jumpsuit
with his ass on fire to go running
through a scene screaming like a girl
and no one said well [ __ ] we can't leave
that it looks like hell but they did
here's your scene from Logan's Run with
a guy with his ass on fire and we'll
show it a couple times in case you
missed it the first time through we're
not going to not gonna watch that that
was a that was a good setup right there
well go to youtube and check it out
ourselves and let's pass around some
laptop so everyone could take a look at
it so let's just say no more no more
videos tonight no more
choose no more okay how about pictures
they'll have pictures or let's move on
to the next segment that we like to call
keV in this is a segment where we take
Kevin Kevin Smith that is and we insert
him into into situations you wouldn't
necessarily be in oh it sounded erotic
for a second no no it's it this is you
in funny pictures basically it's called
Kevin what's Kevin this week
let's take a look oh yeah keep those
coming today the three new Kevin
pictures that were set in this week by
various fans Tom in Somerville
Massachusetts said whenever sees Kevin
he thinks of the movie 2001 a Space
Odyssey
he thinks of Kevin being the space baby
at the end the fetus that that cured
alia sees at the end of the film and it
promises everlasting life that goes on
and on through the cosmos here's Kevin
you know but this Kevin was an actor
early on in his life he played this bass
baby back in the late 60s here you go
here's Kevin as the space baby from 2001
a Space Odyssey
if you don't show me that picture I'm
gonna go up there and just throttle you
I'm serious
we got no picture huh no nothing nothing
visual wah-wah video no signal how about
just still pictures again there's still
pictures help me please we got that
picture why can't we have other pictures
I don't know either all right well we're
just gonna move on from that's all right
we're gonna know it's cool tonight we're
gonna just go we're just going to go
HIGHlarious audio comedy and oh that's
warm up here it's time to take a look at
the week's showbiz news Kevin with a
segment we like to call HBO headline
[Music]
the expendables twos in theaters this
weekend getting big big box office
summer is a weekend that's like yeah
they're already talking about
Expendables 3 that's how successful it
is producer avi Lerner was talking to
the high word reporter this week and he
said he said it's got his a list of
action stars from the past that he wants
to include into the Expendables cast
because it's only it's a draw mostly
from from stars of action films gone by
he got stallone he got John Claude Van
Damme Dolph Lundgren Schwarzenegger
Bruce Willis I think they're there their
requests are a little high for the next
one he says they're already in talks
with these actors to be in the next film
really Nicolas Cage they want to have
Nicolas Cage a but that one I get that
one I can kind of see cuz I'm more of an
Expendables protector I really want to
be in your film I think it'd be great to
be expandable Clint Eastwood then when I
joined Clint Eastwood today yeah I can't
imagine that would happen though he
doesn't need it
and he'd break a hip more importantly
it's a half time in America and I just
[ __ ] myself and Harrison Ford they'd
like to add to the to the cast what do
you do you think he would say yes
John mr. Church already
[Laughter]
producer says they'd even extend an
invitation to Wesley Snipes of course
when he's out of prison that I could see
I could see the Wesley's I think Clint
Eastwood is shooting very high I can't
imagine he says yes he can't do any
action film just 11d any but he doesn't
need to he's got another movie coming
out man I drove past Warner Brothers
another whole set of the building it's
him sitting in some stands at a baseball
game that's the whole movie that's what
I'm saying you can't do that really The
Expendables you have to be able to
physically lift a gun I don't think he
has that power any longer what what if
he was like wasn't uh Arnold in the
church in the first one like he didn't
lift a gun or anything no he just came
in - you think - that's a picture that's
a picture oh oh it's okay it's okay we
got it we got some we got some good
audio here we got Taylor Swift's new
song Taylor Swift just dropped her new
song this week that talentless [ __ ]
she's got a new song out oh really all
she does is [ __ ] guys break up with him
then write about them that's her that's
her that's her that's her formula for
success how do you know that [ __ ] she's
no woman we that angry at a guy if she
didn't [ __ ] him that's how I know that
she's not like most songs because he
took back his promise ring okay he
[ __ ] her and he left her and now she's
like oh yeah I'm gonna show you I'm
gonna write a really bad country pop
song about you and that'll teach you so
she's got a new one that dropped this
week called we are never ever getting
back together again I [ __ ] you not the
song really yes it is as if someone
opened up a 12 year old girl's diary and
just set it to music
this woman's 22 years old yeah they're
Swift now at some point you gotta say
get the [ __ ] over it will you move on
she's dating an eighteen year old guy by
the way
one of the Kennedys kind of Connor
Kennedy yeah he's 18 she's 22 yes young
dick that shows that she's emotionally
immature what 22 year old woman wants to
be with an 18 year old boy and she by
bone de before he was 18 so she's also a
statutory rapist
she's a talentless statutory rapist as
what I'm saying let's hear this song I
want to hear it you want to hear we're
never ever ever getting together again
ever ever ever [ __ ] with the title
like that it's got to be good here's
here's I hope I hope I hope it's a song
from Taylor Swift
[Music]
I'm gonna change trust me remember how
that lasted for a day I say I hate you
we break up you call me I love you no
I'm not doing that to that what she
didn't say we are never ever getting
back up because I don't have an hour to
play that song but trust me it's in
there she gets somebody said that's not
country he puts the content country sir
I beg to differ
that is absolutely country so weird man
you're like anyone who's a successful
kid I hate I don't hate successful kids
I hate talentless successful okay we're
like the Voldemort of entertainment why
can't your baby and I Swifton give me
her soul first of all you're not gonna
find one in Taylor Swift I am just
against talentless kids having success I
like talented kids okay oh there's got
to be some made some kids on the whip
your hair back no [ __ ] no not that one
not Willow Smith Taylor Swift is the
Willow Smith of country music oh yes it
says Ralph Garman [ __ ] she's hit she's
Hitler's what Taylor Swift is she's paid
off Swit ler yeah Bieber's another one
[ __ ] Bieber
however you want to talk about talent
all right let's get on to town let's
talk about another new single that
dropped this week from the Octomom
that's right her song sexy party is
finally available I showed you the cover
of its of the single I think oh I'm
never mind I was I was going to show you
a picture yes we all are a lot better
off having not seen Octomom with her
tits hanging out on that but the song
sexy party did did get released this
week it is her new dance wraps and I
wouldn't be right of me if I didn't play
a little of sexy party by Nadya Suleman
please enjoy
[Music]
when does she sing
she says bother me for an autograph then
then talk of trash behind my back don't
make me laugh she says that was her
singing oh yeah I was like the breakdown
before she comes no that's her that's
her being [ __ ] by a robot and she
sings she sings that that way the whole
song is just it's magical I prefer the
teller so I have to agree
that's Kristen Stewart apparently has
been dropped from plans for a Snow White
sequel yeah I've heard varying versions
of the story well the one I read was
that they're gonna take Chris Hemsworth
character the Huntsman and they are
going to shoot him off on his spin-off
but the other version I heard is they
were always gonna do this even after
eventually cuz they well he's money
right now they figured him you know
coming off [ __ ] Avengers this dude
they could spit him off as just the
Huntsman and stuff so they were already
talking about doing this before you know
she was like I love British director
[ __ ] or whatever she said I believe
those were her actual words yeah there's
a certain apparently there's a [ __ ]
clause in her contract no one knew this
they are gonna bounce her from the
project and they're gonna develop Chris
Hemsworth and as funny thing is the
irony is that Rupert Sanders the British
director may be back to direct the
sequel with Chris Hemsworth and she's
just as guilty as she is but she's
getting jettison and he might keep his
job I read an article where she was
now that's just us don't don't get
excited there's a video of Ralphie Kevin
up what this curry no it's it's live
it's happening we're here so Rupert
Sanders directing Chris Hemsworth it's
the it's the Huntsman directed by the
consummate excuse ironic it's time for
us to take a look at Kim car I'm sorry
porn star Kim Kardashian
[Music]
Kim has another high-profile detractor
this week jon hamm is famously said that
she or she and her family are super
disgusting which I love that quote
double-oh-seven Daniel Craig said
they're [ __ ] idiots this week jeremy
renner okay hawkeye himself has come
forward and said that the Kardashians
according to this interview with The
Guardian are ridiculous people with zero
towel to spend their lives making sure
everyone knows their name I knew Jeremy
was one of the good ones in a related
story the Kardashians released their
eyewear line this week so if you want to
get their glasses you can pick them up
at Sears which is where you go for high
quality eyewear and I imagine that's I
were to keep coming from hitting you in
the eye or their [ __ ] goggles basically
that story let's do this story anyway
even without the video you're about dave
mustaine the lead singer from Megadeth
you're at this what the what
Wow can we show Katy Perry's ass then
can we jump forward to that
no pictures just video all right well
let's show dave mustaine
this is great this is like sound ratbag
totally that's let's show Dave Mustaine
Megadeth singer in Singapore being
[ __ ] batshit crazy let's show that
because he talks about our President
Barack Obama and regardless of how you
may feel about the man I'm pretty sure
he's not staging shootings which is what
Dave Mustaine said this week that he was
doing you won't believe this when you
hear it let's watch this video hopefully
back in my country my president was
trying to pass a gun ban
so he's staging all of these tomorrow's
like a fast and furious thing down at
the border and no more Colorado all the
people that were killed there and now
two beautiful people at the Sikh temple
[Music]
stop keeps a JDR promoter here tonight
what a great guy I was saying you know I
don't know where I'm gonna live if
America keeps going the way it's going
because it looks like he's turning into
Nazi America Dave Mustaine in Singapore
said President Obama is staging all
those shootings he killed the people in
Aurora Colorado and the Sikh temple and
he is he's killing Americans because he
wants to ban guns that's why he's
staging those those killings he's put it
all together like Jessica Fletcher he
really is for murder she wrote he said
America is turning into Nazi America he
doesn't know where he's gonna live so
Singapore tag you're it you got him out
Singapore is an awesome place to live
you cannot allowed to chew gum or spit
it out you get fined or arrested or
caned yeah yeah I want to see cannot see
America wait today that are caning you
for your bad 80s hairdo Dave Mustaine
wait I want to see that story go to that
story you wanna go this story she did
Jones I feel bad rashida Jones who was
on Parks and Recreation very talented
funny she was she was in the office for
a while too she is the daughter of
Quincy Jones and Peggy Lipton very
talented woman she's got a new movie
coming out and she was talking to a
publication about the fact that she's
got a lot of gay friends and she wishes
more high-profile gay people would come
out she said a movie star should come
out John Travolta basically she said she
said his name yes it's time John
Travolta come on come out how many
masseuse have to come forward let's do
this
I mean she's not wrong you know it's
it's still so weird so boom she is back
peddling furiously this week after she
made that comment she tweeted on Tuesday
made a thoughtless comment about John
Travolta I sincerely apologize nobody's
personal life is my business it's classy
now will the Scientologist please remove
the bomb from my car she says apparently
they did Baywatch star Donna de areco
had an accident this week she apparently
was at Mount Ararat in Turkey she was on
a hike and she had a major fall hurting
her face and arms and legs she was
looking for Noah's Ark yeah she was on
an expedition looking for Noah's Ark
weight in Turkey with a TV show
no no just a group of people looking for
Noah's Ark Kevin this is awesome yeah I
mean I'm sad she got hurt but really she
took a major fall really got hurt while
with her expedition who were by the way
if I didn't mention it looking for
Noah's Ark in Mount Ararat in Turkey did
she find Jesus you know what you didn't
find
Noah's Ark you know why no [ __ ]
Noah's Ark yeah it's just the story even
when I was a kid in Catholic school they
told us the lie that the nuns would be
well they weren't nuns they were sisters
but they were like Noah's Ark is a
parable yeah it didn't really happen
nobody could collect two of every animal
and it's just for today didn't rain for
40 days 49 exam these were people in
like uniforms you know wearing black
yeah normally they're Chip Feeny all
sorts of [ __ ] but this time around
our [ __ ] teacher was like
she wants to finish out the final two
days of the journey before flying back
to the States because apparently it
takes a lot of planning research and
permits to do this trip she said she's
going back next month to continue the
search Donna let me save you some time
and effort and apparently some bruising
and cuts there's no [ __ ] Noah's Ark
just like you weren't a real life guard
on Baywatch
next up the North Pole I'm gonna find
Santa but [ __ ] kills me that's what
she said Shia LaBeouf was sober for a
while because it kept getting into
drunken brawls and bars okay
is this do you have more Shia stuff I
just the fact that he is drinking again
okay
he said he had to get drunk for his role
as a Prohibition era bootlegger in the
movie lawless I did it for the movie
he said about falling off the wagon [ __ ]
and this is a great story I didn't drink
offset for no reason I did it because
when I showed up on the set the next day
my [ __ ] eyes looked like this in my
face had that drunk bloat than I needed
and I couldn't have had it if I wasn't
going on so he had to get drunk for the
movie people he's doing it for you do
you appreciate that yes he was sewn
character that his co-star Mia
Wasikowska Wasikowska yeah she was
Alison Alison Wunderland yep
she called her agent and wanted to be
taken off the movie because he was
[ __ ] drunk all the time
but he was doing it for the movie so by
[ __ ] up the movie he was really
helping the movie see you're a piece of
[ __ ] Shia LaBeouf he he's been out
promoting that movie I read a few quotes
that he gave you in some interview he
was talking about remember he made some
aunt not auntie but some critical
comments of Indiana Jones and then dis
Gilbert oh there's Kevin as the star
baby 17 jokes ago he apparently did like
took some [ __ ] for it man
see it would have been fun honey yeah
baby eternity he he took some [ __ ] for
it and he said that he said the
Spielberg quote that he said this is
what Steven Spielberg said and if he did
say it I'm like oh my god sing you
understand but it's kind of
heartbreaking when he said like you know
drop do you drop the ball or whatever
Spielberg's comment to him was there's a
time to be honest and there's a time to
just sell cars Wow and so he was telling
him like shut the [ __ ] up and sell this
[ __ ] Edsel yeah and when you write
your life story at the end you can tell
all the truth you want I was weird man
but that's it's I thought it was weird
that he was critical of Spielberg in the
first place very ballsy yeah but weird
but then even weirder that he like he
was saying like I we don't talk anymore
we you know he was obviously mad at the
thing I said and then he goes oh by the
way he said this other [ __ ] thing as
well I just want make sure we never talk
again yes I was doing yeah he's I don't
know go read some Shia LaBeouf
interviews right now he is just
literally back on the sauce so he's
interesting is that what's going on oh
my god he's just saying some [ __ ]
Harrison Ford said [ __ ] drunk that's
my new favorite addition in the news
this week
[Applause]
why don't you come to your senses
last year Lindsay Lohan was broke had no
[ __ ] money this year they say she's
gotta make close to two million dollars
when you add it all up right on yeah
it's not right on I mean at least she's
not stealing it that's stealing
necklaces anymore with her playboy gig
which was a million dollars plus the
$300,000 they gave her for Liz and Dick
which is more money than she's gotten
for dick in a long time
200 grand from that scary movie
installment that she's doing plus an
endorsement for jag jeans
I don't what jag jeans are but
apparently she sells them and then she
gets two to ten thousand dollars per
tweet for certain companies for doing
those advertising tweets that yeah they
say if you total it up she's she's on
the road to having two million dollars
at her fingertips this year that is
that'll last for a weekend with the
right cocaine dealer and the Chateau
Marmont so congratulations Michael J Fox
is talking about coming back to
television this yeah he is in talks with
a director the guy who directed Easy A
which you know is a movie I love with
Emma Stone and Will Gluck is his name
our writer for Cougar Town they're
trying to put together a sitcom which
would basically be about a celebrity
dealing with a chronic illness and how
crazy his life gets and they would do a
comedy about and this is I guess
spinning off of the Curb Your Enthusiasm
appearance and his Good Wife work as
well too which is also he's in that too
he has a recurring character as a as a
lawyer with Parkinson's and as getting
Emmy nominations for both of those roles
so he's saying maybe he'll come back to
to television as someone who's suffering
from that illness and you get to watch
it every week which sounds [ __ ] a
wino that's like that's you might as
well let him if he's willing to go out
there and kind of but do you think that
would be funny every week yeah I would
imagine you know maybe he'd find a way
look the dudes gifted yes strong
performer I agree he has great comedic
instinct yeah he's an absolute [ __ ]
pro he's unfortunately like he's got his
version of a [ __ ] cold is this thing
so for him to be able to work
for him to be able to work through it
without yelling at James and [ __ ] uh-oh
okay I see how it's gonna be I'm the bad
guy no doubt at all but I don't know I
think it'd be I be intelligence I can
find a way to make that funny I mean
look that how cool would that be
if they're like we're just gonna break
down this taboo and we open up a whole
new world for people who are performers
who have disabilities who would like to
be Leeds total and also like the dudes
an actor and his heart and soul and has
been for all of his life and I imagine
like you know aside from the incredible
inconvenience or whatever his condition
carries with it it also stops him from
doing the one thing that he's really
nice whole life doing and for good
reason not just because like all the
money's green he [ __ ] loved acting so
the chance for him to go back and start
acting even if it is just playing this
guy we're playing Parkinson's all the
time I say it apps grab hold of it ya
know it sounds a little shaky to me
[Applause]
Ralph go back and tell him and don't
make that joke sorry doc and a last bit
of TV news Spike television this week
announced that they're bringing back a
TV show called the Joe Schmo show I can
finally talk about why I had that
horrible beard for a couple of weeks
there in July I am the host again of the
Joe Schmo show in January for those of
you who aren't familiar with the Joe
Schmo show it was a spoof on reality
television where we took one person who
thought he was actually competing on a
reality TV show and surrounded him with
improvisational comic actors who are all
playing roles and we would put on a it
was a put on we would put on this entire
show for his benefit and at the end we
would reel to him why his world was so
bizarre and so crazy and then we'd
shower him with prizes and gifts and
hope he didn't kill us all
so we've done that again it'll be on in
January of next year and I think you're
all going to enjoy it I play a bounty
hunter who is hosting a bounty hunting
reality competition show and the winner
of that show gets $100,000 and gets to
be my protege bounty hunter from my
bounty hunting service and one of the
competitors is TVs Lorenzo Lamas who of
course played a bounty hunter as
renegade for many seasons and he's
playing himself as a competitor on the
show but he's in on the joke yes he's
one of the actors who knows what's going
on is only one guy who's a guy just a
regular Joe Schmo off the street who
just comes in and he thinks he's
actually competing when in reality the
whole thing's rigged but it's not
Lorenzo Lorenzo it's not the Schmo no
the Lorenzo is very funny
I was very self-effacing and does a
great job of playing like a Hollywood
douchebag look at you man so wait your
idea of being a tough guy is growing a
beard well I was gonna put on a hockey
jersey and look really tough [ __ ] you
[Applause]
let's take a look at this week's key
clues
[Music]
Davida company says he'd like to another
x-files movie that's not all he's like
Dave now that you're banging Julia I
don't know if that's true or not but I
still I want to believe I want to but
yes Dave the company says everyone that
Fox should want to do it because they
have a homegrown action franchise that
is excellent he says you don't need to
invest in buying the rights for a comic
book or anything it's already good to go
it should be a summer film it should be
an action film he said the last one we
made was not it was a dark contemplative
film the last one wasn't very action for
the thinker's film and but to be fair
the first one wasn't really all that
action it was sort of a tide in the two
seasons was happening while the show was
going on so there's a lot of it that's
that awesome opening with sequence with
the the daredevil franchises in danger
over at Fox there been a lot of talk
about them wanting to hold on to the
rights and and making a deal with Marvel
so that they could do the film
eventually but it looks like the
director that was interested joe
carnahan who did the grey and a team he
pitched them an idea of a daredevil it
took place in the 70s like a hard-boiled
Serpico she watched the thing that he
puts here yeah it was put together like
a sizzle reel that was comprised of a
lot of 70s flicks like taxi driver and
whatnot and then a few shots from the
daredevil that Ben Affleck was in whoa
what they were making it I'm still
daredevil right Jennifer so it looks
like he has been passed over as director
they're just running out of time so it
looks like the rights to daredevil may
revert back to Marvel which may be
better for everybody well they're
talking about giving it to them because
Marvel asked for Galactus and asked for
silver and silver surfer yeah and Fox
has Fantastic Four and they're like well
no we're not we'd rather hold on to
those but more of a sure thing for them
daredevil instead I think is what
they've been horse-trading a little bit
but that'd be bad preferred if Marvel
had control of all their characters at
this point they do a good job doing a
great [ __ ] job
speaking of which Robert Downey jr.
injured his ankle while filming a stunt
on the set of Iron Man 3 oh they're not
doing that good a job then yeah they're
not taking care of their stars so there
will be a short delay in production
apparently they're gonna have to suspend
production while he heals up [ __ ]
they've got a start date a rather a a
release date for Avengers the next
Avengers movie mark your calendars get
your calendars out right now I'm giving
you the the tip May 1st 2015 so make
sure you're not doing anything on that
day that's when we're gonna see Avengers
2 Buccaneers there's four films ahead of
it there's Iron Man 3 which is gonna be
delayed because he's too [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's in May of 2013
poor man porcelain ankle that's
should've wore the suit Tony
Thor the dark world November 2013
Captain America the Winter Soldier May
2014 and guardians of the galaxy August
2014 that's leading everything up so I'm
are you I don't even know what the [ __ ]
that is I think it rocket racoon or
record what is it rocket rocket racoon
literally I mean it looks like it'll be
more kid-friendly than anything else cuz
most of the characters are like a big
tree man a little raccoon dude
but it's it's not when you think of
Marvel it's not what immediately comes
to mind I'm curious where this all fits
in in the grand scheme of things right
again as we just said before they're
doing smart things over there but this
one is to me a little puzzling they must
know something about guardians of the
galaxy racoon doesn't hurt his ankle or
else it's gonna throw the schedule away
in the [ __ ] and while we're talking
about movies this is a great piece of
film that I hope will be able to show
you it's on YouTube but a lot of the
listeners of Hollywood babble-on sent it
over to us I thought I'd share it with
you guys it's from a production company
called happy Dragon pictures they took
the 1966 animated opening to the Batman
TV series and they've redrawn it for the
Dark Knight franchise so we're gonna
show it to you tonight it is it's pretty
amazing you can go on YouTube and check
it out but also I want to give credit to
happy dragon pictures the people put it
together here's the 1966 Batman opening
updated and revamped for the Dark Knight
franchise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well done by their very impressive first
every week we have a musical question
we'd like to ask you just how big is
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] of course this all
stems from Kevin's fascination with the
size of Liam Neeson's member if you have
a fact about his member that you know
you'd like to share with the rest of us
it's Neeson [ __ ] calm you can go to and
add it this is that should be a joke by
by the way don't just [ __ ] right in
and be like I hear it's veiny no exactly
I hope people understand that it's
supposed to be a joke this is some of
our favorites from this week Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that it was the
first image sent back from the Mars
Curiosity rover scientific mrs. [ __ ] is
so big it doesn't just have a urethra
it has urethra Franklin that's a bigger
wreath right I give that joke respect
I will not file tonight when you're
going home with the freeway of love
you're gonna say that was not a good
idea
[ __ ] who's uma new route Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that once a day
he lowers a basket down as urethra and
shouts to the woman at the bottom it
rubs the lotion on its skin Liam Neeson
closer to the basket Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big he wasn't circumcised he was
circumcised that's cute
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's who
the Ghostbusters call who are you gonna
call Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it
here's a Horten Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big
Freddie Mercury was projected on it
during the Olympic closing ceremonies
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when he
gets a [ __ ] the national unemployment
rate drops two percentage points I did
not know that
lambie's his [ __ ] is so big he's
developed a hands-free sex position that
he likes to call Schindler's lift and
lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it
likes pina coladas and getting caught in
the rain it is not into yoga and it has
half a brain it likes making love at
midnight in the dunes on the Cape it's
the love that you've looked for right to
it and escape so sweet so sweet ladies
and gentlemen of Hollywood have you
enjoyed yourselves this evening thank
you for putting up with all our nonsense
thank you for bearing with us through
the technical difficulties we won't be
here next week but we will be here at
the Jon Lovitz theater uh the following
week I won't be here you'll be here
where are you gonna be here with Jay
Mewes
oh oh on September 1st on September 1st
we're doing Jay and Silent Bob get old
right here at the Lovitz but what you're
not gonna be here the week after will be
here the 8th I'm lost oh yeah next week
we're not gonna be here because we're
gonna be in Canada yes then the week
after that you're gonna be here adjacent
news but you're not gonna be but I won't
be here no you you're off that way
instead of doing Hollywood babble-on
you're doing Jay and Bob get old I feel
like I would just woken up and somebody
was like you've been sleeping my brother
she just pushed you in the bathtub yeah
walking the pushes about and then on the
8th the week after that we return with
Hollywood babble-on here at the lovest
so you're taking a week off Oh for
[ __ ] sake
let's just say goodnight we shall ladies
and gentlemen that is a Hollywood
babble-on for this week I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen give it up for
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman Hollywood
babble-on live at the Lovett
[Music]